[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Sam
[Music]
you know what's crazy to me
how fast time flies like it's week three
already Sam
man I'm in disbelief but anyways let's
talk about your week too how did you do
week two good bad so-so mediocre it was
good man it was good man went four and
two we obviously we cashed on the Niners
together which was great
um rounded it out with just a absolutely
delightful win on Monday Night Football
uh with the Eagles just making Kirk
Cousins and our friend Michael Ritter
was like an absolute idiot so that that
was really enjoyable but yeah good week
Kirk Cousins man Kirk Cousins in prime
time it's I mean it's the same thing
it's it's it's it's literally the same
thing Kirk Cousins in Primetime is a
no-show
that second half was one of the worst
halves of quarterback play I've ever
seen it was the Sam darnold I'm seeing
ghost out there for an entire half it
was it was amazing
and I got my man Justin Jefferson on my
fantasy team bro and I was like I was
competing I was competing to win but
then you know Kirk Cousins goes out
there and just be himself and then we
got guys like Michael Ritter telling the
audience to like put MVP bets on Kirk
cut like come on man tough week for our
guy Ritter not Kirk Cousins hey Kirk we
gotta do better but let's do better
because Sam we're we want to be better
than last week let's get this show
started my name is Greg that is Sam
Richmond and um if you guys were here
last week you guys know we introduced
producer Ryan so I would like to
reintroduce producer Ryan welcome to the
show brother uh look look at Ryan look
at his setup Sam he has the whole setup
podcast Mike headphone Studio like must
be nice right
yeah man I showed up ready to go it's a
shout out to the crew here in New York
they got me uh they got me well lit the
blue for my Cowboys tomorrow when they
beat the Giants so I know we don't have
a Monday show but Cowboys money line
just letting you guys know but yeah no
it's nice in here
hey Ryan
we're putting Sam on the clock this week
because my man he's been he's been he's
been
he's been up in uh
even about his pick so we're putting Sam
on the clock this week
can you keep your picks to 30 seconds or
less I actually want to bet on that Ryan
I'm taking the over which way are you
leaning I I have I have the over as well
but I'm gonna try my best I have this
Bell to ring for him when you know what
he should shut up so uh maybe it's my
best interest to take the under because
I think I could control that
all right Sam collusion
you were on the clock brother you were
on the clock hey but all eyes are on you
we want to know what are the six Best
Bets of the week
Mike goes to you brother all right quick
starting off Colts plus six I get it
they've looked awful this is your
classic buy low spot in the NFL it
happens all the time they're coming home
they couldn't have looked worse this
line probably would have been like plus
three at the start of the season but
people are overreacting so give me six
points at home with a good team uh I
expect them to bounce back here and
since I have eight seconds uh I just
want to say yesterday was the worst day
of my life as a Mizzou football fan boom
quick I love the way we were right to it
right there Sam so we're rocking with
the coats plus six as the first pick
Sam talk to me talk to the people what
are we rocking with next and we are on
the clock
a lot of ugly picks I'm not gonna lie
I'm sure I'm getting roasts in the
comments but I like commanders plus six
and a half again in this league you buy
low you sell High we're selling high in
the Eagles here again before that Monday
Night Football masker this line probably
would have been like eagles minus three
minus four
you got you got to go against that
overreaction you're not going to
long-term win money betting this league
if you're taking three points extra give
me the six and a half Carson wins does
not look that bad uh my clock is up I'm
done
boom I like that Sam I like that little
overreaction from The Eagles I like that
now talk to me about the third Pig which
way are we leaning
say this is a theme I just it's ugly
underdogs I am who I am Panthers plus
two and a half again they've looked
awful they've lost nine straight games
overall this is when you buy low in this
league coming home Owen two a must win
game the coach is gonna get fired this
is when we bet on this team when
everyone is against him and they have to
win a game uh Saints offense has looked
really bad especially last week I think
the Panthers though every single thing
they have in this game they have to have
it to stay alive so give me the two and
a half on the home
Sam we got the new buzzer we got the new
buzzer to stop I've been in the buzzer
no no no you are beating the buzzer but
I just wish we had like a freeze button
because that pick was cold that pick is
hot I mean not hot but it's ice cold I
don't know about the Panthers but it's
not it's not
I am who I am I don't know like I'm
gonna get roast in the comments
everyone's gonna tell me I'm an idiot
like that that's who I am I expect it
hey that that's what it is as long as
you expect it then hey that's that's all
we can expect I don't know I don't even
know what I'm trying to say but what I
am trying to say is that the Panthers
the Panthers uh I don't know about that
Sam but it's not up to me it's up to the
people Ryan talk to us what are the
people saying in the comments brother
are they all on Sam's are they all on
his favor or are they uh roasting them
in the comments oh I'd be remiss to not
address the haters here we have uh a
liebe Dune uh says that Sam's picks were
not good last week why do we listen to
him they went forward too that's what I
was gonna say four and two I mean these
people come in here expected 6-0 don't
parlay the picks forward to its profit
uh whatever we're we're moving on uh
Brendan Rich Eagles get in touch today
I'm assuming that means he likes your
Commander's pick uh the life of Smitty
uh commanders cover the spread uh we've
got uh I want to win says commanders to
cover so we're all over we're all all
over the the commanders uh in here yeah
uh Jags magic uh money line for the
Eagles uh C Brown she's probably gonna
max out them Colts today so uh I mean
he's like 93 of the public who is all
over the Chiefs today so that's the show
I just want a personal apology from the
person who wrote it like that's gonna
bother me for the rest of the show I
went four and two you can't tell me my
picks were trash I would like you to
personally apologize in the comments by
the end of the show thank you yeah Sam
we're gonna work on those we're going to
work on that commenter apologizing but
before he apologizes we need to work on
the last three legs of your six Best
Bets you got three you gave us Colts
plus six commanders plus six and a half
and those Panthers I don't know about
that spread let's talk about the last
three Sam and remember you are on the
clock brother
all right same thing same thing here
we're we're going the other way we like
the Dolphins today uh Ryan I think I
sent you this tweet so uh you're gonna
have to read it out loud so I don't get
on the shot clock but the bills defense
is completely beat up this week I think
they're missing four to five starters
they're starting a bunch of rookies in
the secondary uh that is a tough task
when you're going against waddle and
Tyrique and the Dolphins pass offense
looks a little bit better than even I
expected five points for the home dog
we're gonna sell High a little on the
bills here
there it is it might be a track meet out
there I it might be a track meet out
there we will see let's move on to the
fifth pick Sam
all right I feel like I might get some
approval on this one at least more so in
relation to my other ones but Packers
plus one and a half the Bucks are really
beat up they're missing pretty much
their entire receiving core they could
not move the ball at all last week and
they really kind of struggled uh in week
one two kind of sneakily against the
Cowboys moving the ball I think they
scored one touchdown so uh I like the
Packers this week I think they're better
than the bucks
um yeah I don't know there's just a lot
that scares me about Tampa Bay right now
uh they can't move the ball they've got
no receivers they're beat up on the
offensive line I like the back to win
suspensions injuries they are beat up
out there in Tampa Bay I don't dislike
that one Sam I do not dislike that one
at all leading to the last pick the last
and final pick talk to me Sam talk to
the people which way are you leaning
you're not gonna like this one but
Broncos plus one and a half well I need
the [ __ ] I get it Broncos have looked
absolutely horrendous I I can't defend
it but again in this league and this
spot this is when teams usually show up
they've been getting beat up for two
weeks they have a prime time spot at
home to kind of shut everyone up and get
the train back on the tracks uh their
dvoa and their Advanced metrics aren't
actually as bad as the results have been
uh I still think this is a good team I
think they win in a desperation spot at
home 30 seconds boom beat your clock
Ryan
Sam I don't like that one and I'll be
honest I don't like that when I think
the Niners go into a mile high and turn
up today uh Ryan talk to me talk to the
people hopefully the people I mean which
way are the people leaning are they
leaning towards my decisions and not
agreeing with Sam
or are they leaning towards the other
way in rhyming with my man Sam what are
they talking about in the comments so I
think we needed to kill the bad vibes in
the last segment we just needed to
address them and move on uh Big Mike
says that he trusts you Sam he's riding
with you uh the life of Smitty says I
like Colts plus six as well it's a solid
lock uh Dolphins plus five and a half
also a lock uh
Hunter Harmon says Cults are trash uh
Michael bowling wants to talk about how
you are dead on time today Sam that
there is there's no going over the the
shot clock you're you're right on it
it's it's pretty impressive obviously
I'm not a look at me praise myself guy
but really impressive by me uh Jags
magic uh love that Packers pick deep
price Real Talk bills defense is
depleted which uh good point you did
send me a tweet uh the pill starting
secondary today
Islam who's their rookie first round
pick uh Christian Benford rookie sixth
round pick Damar Hamlin 20 21 six round
pick and Tequan Johnson 2019 sixth round
pick so uh this three total starts among
those guys and they're gonna keep up
with tyreik and model good luck good
luck we will see good luck good luck all
right get in the comments and tell us
who you are betting to score today
because here are a few to choose from
we're gonna go quick Sam we're gonna go
quick through this uh top five most bet
anytime touchdowns props on DraftKings
right now Travis Kelsey at -130 he is
the fifth most bet Jamar Chase plus 110
is the fourth
most bet Sam how do you feel about Jamar
Chase getting into the end zone Travis
Kelsey there he is and then Jamar Chase
plus 110. do you think he can get in
today Sam
I mean I think he I mean look this is a
desperation spot for the Bengals I'm
assuming they're going to go to their
best guys so at plus money I think it's
interesting
hey plus money with Jamar Chase I like
it I like it let's move on Jalen hurts
we were talking about this Sam they just
faced that Vikings team Jalen hurts to
get an Enzo minus 110 he is the third
most bet uh-oh Aman ra Saint Brown he is
plus money today Sam plus 135 he's the
second most bet uh two score today in
rounding it off rounding it off Stefon
Diggs Stefon Diggs sitting at minus 110
is the most bet touchdown scorer today
Sam out of all of them I know you
touched on Jamar Chase
and the plus money but out of all of
those guys or anybody anybody in the
league who do you think is getting in
the end zone today
oh I get anybody in the league
um I'm going with Jonathan Taylor uh I
think again I think this is actually a
really good spot where the Colts have
looked really bad and they actually
haven't got Jonathan Taylor nearly as
involved so I think this is a week where
they're like hey we need to play better
we need to get our best player of the
ball Chiefs Rush defense little suspect
so uh I like Taylor getting the end zone
today
Sam's rocking with uh Jonathan Taylor
Sam I'm going with another running back
but I'm going to Tennessee Derrick Henry
they're facing the Raiders I talked week
after week about that Raiders defense
and uh I don't see anything changing I
think my man Derek Henry is going to be
able to run the ball and if they get on
the goal line we know what they're gonna
do we know that they're going to give it
to Derek Henry it's what they did last
week uh but Ryan talk to me you got my
pick you got Sam's pick what is the
audience deciding who are they picking
we got a lot of takes in here KP Giants
heard the Tweet heard the stat on the
bills secondary and loves Tyrique and
Jalen waddle uh to go off today uh Big
Mike likes uh Jamar Chase anytime TD uh
Jags magic Debo anytime TD uh
we've got Rafi La cap who likes Brandon
iyuk and Michael bowling drop in the
comment is specifically direct quote
Justin Jefferson is a hammer lead pipe
quiet quad diamond lock
it doesn't get any more lucky than that
yeah so
let's think about that a little bit
though Michael Bowen I like the way he's
thinking Kirk Cousins didn't have a good
game last week you think he bounces back
oh boy all right guys we're putting
trust in Kirk Cousins I thought we don't
do that on the show Justin Jefferson is
so good he can overcome Kirk Cousins
though I'll say that
Justin Jefferson Ryan what so what's the
audience deciding what what are we doing
yeah we're galvanizing around Justin
Jefferson right now I think we just
needed to say it and then everyone
starts uh rallying around it
um you know we've got Devante Adams
we've got Stefan Diggs but it seems like
this is a Justin Jefferson kind of weak
guys
I mean I like the
liked earlier in the show uh he's on my
fantasy team so I actually like this I
like this a lot I think big big bounce
back hopefully we're we're sending Good
Vibes sending Good Vibes into the air
big bounce back game for Kirk Cousins
today and we're going to get Justin
Jefferson into the end zone
actually that was boosted that thing's
boosted from minus 165 to plus 100 shout
out to our friends hat DraftKings and if
you want a parlay if you want to Parlay
all three picks my pick Sam's pick and
yours DK will boost it 25
uh by 25 be our betting any time
touchdown uh there it is BR Benz anytime
painter parlay there it is that's what
it's called be our veterans Pay Dirt
parlay
it's right there you guys can go get it
right there on DraftKings
um now it's time for my favorite part of
the show Sam
you last week last week
we we were close what happened what
happened
Sam I I kind of don't want to talk about
it but I'll I'll in the past in the past
we're moving on
Indianapolis Colts didn't show up but
that's okay that that that's okay we're
back we are back this week we're going
to give you guys a set of 10 likes we're
going to do a eight leg parlay and we're
gonna see this one go in we're gonna see
this one going Sam I'm gonna get a start
I'm Gonna Get It Started uh first pick
first pick actually let's bring up Ryan
Ryan
first pick
is
the Kansas City Chiefs plus six and a
half I think that that one's gonna be I
think that one's gonna be easy against
the Colts Sam you're taking a spread
with the coach but no Kansas City plus
six and a half I like that spread better
let's lock it in moving on Miami
Dolphins plus 17 and a half against
those Buffalo Bills you said it Sam I
mean you're taking the Dolphins you you
talked about their uh the bills
so I like it move move along let's move
along
the Detroit Lions plus 20 and a half
I don't think the Vikings is gonna go
blow them out so I can see the Lions
keeping that one close
now the Las Vegas Raiders now I I don't
really like the bet on the Las Vegas
Raiders but uh
you know in this situation I'm taking
the Raiders plus 10 and a half points
against Tennessee Titans those Titans
they they just don't impress me with
Ryan Tannehill as the quarterback moving
on Jacksonville it makes me it makes me
so happy to see Ryan have to scroll all
the way down again I I missed that from
last week just him scrolling all the way
to the bottom for plus 20 and a half
bets you just can't beat it no it's my
favorite part of the show
Ryan let's find the Jacksonville Jaguars
because I forgot I want you to scroll
brother I want you there it is
Jacksonville Jaguars alternate spread
and then start scrolling to plus 15 and
a half
because that is what we are locking in
against those Chargers I like it uh
Moving On Moving On
Ryan find me the Arizona Cardinals
they're taking on the Rams
Arizona Cardinals taking on the Rams
this is a division matchup
oh that's perfect
that's perfect for what we're trying to
do division matchups should be a close
game right go to the Arizona Cardinal
side and scroll all the way down the
plus 17 please
no because we're betting on this one oh
actually it's at the top it's at the top
we're betting on this one to be a close
there it is the close one moving on to
the San Francisco 49ers Denver Broncos
Ryan San Francisco 49ers Denver Broncos
Jimmy Garoppolo
are you worried that this is just we're
already in a plus money territory with
six legs I mean this is this is pretty
risky
Sam believe in the approach brother but
believe in the approach we were almost
there last week we were almost there we
were almost there last week when we see
this one caches
you guys just stay tuned to be our
betting uh Instagram Tick Tock platforms
because uh we're gonna celebrate let's
move up did you find the 49ers for me
Ryan okay can you scroll all the way
down please and I'm looking for plus 10
and a half
there it is lock that one in for me I
don't see the Niners losing
at all but I don't see them losing by
more than 10 points
now last but not least
I thought we were going Cowboys money
line Greg last but not least
the commanders let's go our communities
there it is and Ryan are they at the top
plus 20 yes they are
lock that one in
now Ryan uh
as he gives out commanders plus 20 just
just means the world to me I love it
skip this no not the slit not the skip
the slip scroll so we can see the slip
and I'm gonna read it all from the top
really quick
all right here we go
you guys ready
let's get right to it cheese
plus six and a half Miami's Dolphins
plus 17 and a half the Detroit Lions
plus 20 and a half the Las Vegas Raiders
plus ten and a half Jacksonville Jaguars
plus 15 and a half the Arizona Cardinals
plus 17 and 17. San Francisco 49ers plus
10 and a half in the Washington
commanders plus 20 lock that one in
we're gonna see a win today Sam we're
turning the tie make sure you guys get
on DraftKings
and lock that one in how you guys
feeling you can see in real time you
know the the arrows pointing down the
line is moving because everyone is
watching the show and going to build
this bet and hammering it so uh that
that's pretty great to see in real time
I mean you know commanders plus 20 just
seeing that uh is just incredible so I'm
rooting for you Greg no meteors this
week
hey I'm just trying to I'm just trying
to win man I'm just trying to win if
we're finding strategies to beat the
casino to win money from the casino and
if we're figuring out ways to do it why
why not why not build a favorites parlay
uh and try to try to try to try to get
some money from the casino man because
that's why we're here that's why you're
here that's why we're here and that's
why
that's what we're trying to do all right
let's move on let's move on to over
under
Sam the top five most bet player props
on DraftKings let's start with the fifth
one Lamar Jackson over or under 214
passing yards it's sitting at plus 105.
I think let's reveal at the same time
Sam three two one
love that going over
Sam
talk to me
you going over he had a good game last
week
I'm I'm all in on Lamar this year like I
gave it out for the for the season start
I think he wins MVP I think he's just on
an absolute war path so any any lamara
I'm taking
there it is Sam Sam spoken all right
card your card over or under one and a
half passing touchdowns
oh this is a tough one Sam I don't even
know which way I'm gonna go with this
one but all right let's go three two one
oh Sam tell us why under
I they're all in two I feel I feel like
they're gonna and cars just throwing the
ball a lot so I feel like again this is
the week where they've they've lost two
games in a row they're gonna run the
ball a little bit more
um so I think he gets vultured at the in
the red zone and he probably throws one
touchdown
yes one of the Raiders running backs
Jacobs Jacobs is questionable so that's
why I'm leaning towards car airing it
out just a little bit more maybe a
garbage touchdown but let's move on Joe
burrow over or under one and a half
passing touchdown sitting at minus 170.
this is the third most bet
uh at DraftKings uh Sam let's reveal on
three one two three
I mean he's got to hit this right he's
got it gotta hit it he's gotta bounce
back Sam enough said enough said
Ryan talk to us producer Ryan what's
going on in the comments what they
talking about
well Greg I don't know what KP Giants
means by this but he says your parlay
looks like a custom Wawa sandwich I'm a
big Wawa guy I think that's a good thing
I I don't think there's anything better
than a custom Wawa sandwich but in
regards to the over under uh Big Mike is
all over Lamar's over he says over for
sure Lamar's ready to get that bag uh
Rob Dog also on the over for Lamar uh
says 250 yards three plus touchdowns uh
Rob dog again all over Derek Carr's over
uh thanks to Devonte uh Carl wins high
is on the under for Derek Carr because
uh Josh Jacobs seems like he's playing I
don't really know the we're not really
sure yet on the information there he
traveled separately uh from the team but
uh he's on the under because of that
hey there it is uh Sam we got a couple
more to go through we got a couple more
producer Ryan to go through hopefully
those comments is still filling up with
Good Vibes
um Josh Allen over under one and a half
passing touchdown sitting at minus 220.
it's the second most bet uh on
DraftKings Sam I think we both gonna
agree with this one uh but let's see
Maybe not maybe not we we don't know
three two one I I'm sorry I went too
quick but yeah I mean the the minus 220
is a little scary but like he's gonna
throw two touchdowns I mean like it's
Josh Allen so uh yeah
it's Josh Allen in 2022 my man's been
bawling absolutely Bali all right here
we go my fantasy quarterback one of my
favorite quarterbacks in the league
that's not on the San Francisco 49ers
Pat Mahone over two and a half passing
touchdown Sam this one's Plus money
this one's plus money kit pack go get
three I hope he does I have them on
fantasy so I think you know which way
I'm leaning but we want to know which
way you leaning let's do it three two
one
cause shut down the Chiefs this week
Colts win the game all right they shut
down my homes and they cover the six
points he's throwing I would say two
touchdowns no two touchdowns this week
Colt's gonna go teddies two two teddies
two teddies my man Sam oh he's he got my
man packing homes going under three
teddies I don't know how I feel about
that one but it's okay the best Tweets
of the week is isn't up next my man
producer Ryan
come give us some good vibes bro what
what was some of the best Tweets of this
past week that you uh that you
accumulated brother
well I got this from you Greg sorry I'm
getting lost in the chat it's gone
completely Rogue right now but I got
this from you 49ers money line putting
all the assets on it
put in all assets everything that you
got 401K savings account mom savings
account put everything on it hey hey
hear me out though hear me out
the Denver Broncos their head coach
offensive coordinator and defensive
coordinator are all in positions that
they've never done before they look
discombobulated the last two weeks
I don't think that that's going to
change I I don't think that that's going
to change 49ers going to run the ball I
think they go get the W out there and
and uh Denver
there it is all right this next one I
got this one's for you Sam
and we're staying on topic hack it might
be generational we've never seen
mistakes like this so early one to watch
a guy he's been the worst coach of the
season so far but uh he hired like a
game specialist heading into this week
to help him with time management type of
decisions this week so he's taken it out
of his hands he's got a clear mind and
so Broncos get it done
you're really betting on some
[Music]
you got it
learn from your mistakes that's called
growth that's called growth I love it
that is gross that is growth but but
that's crazy I can't wait for the
Meltdown tonight during Sunday Night
Football when Sam is asking himself why
he bet on Nathaniel Hackett but
we'll clip this out after when the
Broncos are up 24-nothing oh well
definitely clip that one out for sure 24
nothing wow
and then we got we got Michael Ritter
who I I personally have a beef with him
with this because if he could he would
choose to live in Philadelphia that's
how much he loves Philadelphia sports uh
the Eagles blow out Kirk Cousins uh and
his Vikings and all of a sudden he
reverts to an undefeated season for the
Eagles and tweets out their schedule
guys give me a give me your thoughts on
this but also maybe at Eagle's record
prediction
wow
I mean it's overreaction for sure like
they're gonna lose some games this year
they're not going to go 17-0
um they do have a really easy schedule I
will get rid of that it's a very easy
schedule they're going to win a lot of
games
um I will say that they are going to
lose today the commanders are going to
upset them at home I'm just I'm just
going with all my picks the commander is
going to upset them at home and then the
Colts are going to beat that oh well now
we're down at week 11. so I guess they
don't play the Colts two weeks from now
but that's that's a decently tough
stretch there uh you know around the
week 11 week 12 so they'll lose some
they only go as far as as their
quarterback takes them last week he
looked really really good you look
really good but uh is that going to
continue throughout the year throughout
the adjustments that teams are going to
make who knows their defense is good but
we'll see we will see uh I don't know
man we will see about this Eagles team
they're two they're 2-0 right now my
record prediction is probably 2 and 15.
just to put that on unbiased unbiased
unbiased unbiased
all right guys drop your picks in the
chat and Sam and I will great them Ryan
pick some of those comments from the
chat right uh so me and Sam can uh give
out some grades because they've been
they've been giving us shade they've
been giving us you know Good Vibes and
some shade so it's now time for me and
Sam to uh return that favor back on them
and I'll give them some grades on their
picks yeah give me the guy who told me
my pick sucked and I'm just gonna Auto
give him an F so find that guy
I'm just kidding uh well Paris thinks uh
the Niners are going to quote-unquote
whoop the Broncos tonight so we'll we'll
start with that
oh yeah I wonder where Greg's going
hey I can keep adding plushes
[Laughter]
uh all right we'll go and Chapman
Dolphins money line for getting the
points going with the money line
oh oh you're not like a bee look at like
a bee
yes like I'm usually like a scared
better so I always take the spread but I
I do really like the Dolphins obviously
I bet them I like that yeah I like that
one more Ryan one more and then we're
getting up out of here all right we got
Ed Roberto saying I'm a hater of the
Eagles well I am it's true Uh Kevin
Morgan Devonte Adams anytime touchdown
I like that
[Applause]
nope that's the wrong card B I meant to
give a b grabbed a c b b plus
he's out today
big plus minus big plus minus yeah no
Renfro he's out he's on my fantasy team
too I I don't like that but you know
what they do they do in Las Vegas they
feed Devonte and they're going to
continue to do that uh hey guys it's
been fun though it's it's been fun we
graded the chat they created us we got
producer Ryan involved in this show and
love is set up like
I'm just so so jealous
what's going on uh we got Sam drinking
water consistently throughout the show
I'm watching football for the next 12
hours I gotta like I gotta drink coffee
I gotta drink water I gotta prepare
hydrate gotta hydrate gotta hydrate
hopefully you guys are all hydrating
before this NFL Sunday as well uh and
before we get out of here 49ers money
line put all assets on it my name is
Greg Ivory for Sam Richmond and producer
Ryan
peace
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
yeah yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]